Termenul teleportare cuantică poate suna a science fiction, dar după cum vom discuta în episodul de astăzi
din Qiskit in the Classroom, este o tehnică foarte reală și foarte utilă pentru comunicarea și
rețelele cuantice. Bun venit la Qiskit in the Classroom. În această serie, vom folosi Qiskit pentru a explora câteva concepte fundamentale
acoperite frecvent în cursurile legate de calculul cuantic. Fiecare videoclip este însoțit de un modul interactiv
legat în descrierea de mai jos, așa că asigură-te că îl verifici. Teleportarea este un fel de clișeu din science fiction și fantezie
în momentul de față. O persoană sau un obiect dispare dintr-o locație și apare instantaneu în altă parte.
Oricât de tare ar fi asta, din păcate, acest tip de teleportare cel puțin este imposibil. Ar încălca limita cosmică
a vitezei. Nimic nu poate călători mai repede decât lumina. Dar teleportarea cuantică este
posibilă. În teleportarea cuantică, informația, nu materia, poate fi transmisă între două
locații îndepărtate. Tot ce ai nevoie este o pereche de particule entanglate, câte una la fiecare locație, și o modalitate de a comunica informații clasice
între cele două locații. Acest protocol a fost dezvoltat în 1993 de o echipă
de oameni de știință cuantici, inclusiv Charles Bennett de la IBM. L-au numit teleportare cuantică deoarece, similar cu versiunea
din science fiction, informația cuantică a dispărut dintr-o locație și a apărut în altă locație îndepărtată
fără a călători niciodată prin spațiul intermediar. Poate suna ca magie, dar, după cum vom vedea, nu există nimic
misterios sau magic în asta. Este posibilă datorită fenomenului de entanglement cuantic împreună cu comunicarea
clasică. Astăzi vom parcurge protocolul de teleportare cuantică și cum funcționează. Și apoi îl vom pune în
practică pe un calculator cuantic real pentru a teleporta starea unui qubit de pe o parte a unui procesor cuantic IBM pe
cealaltă. Iată cum funcționează teleportarea cuantică. Să presupunem că avem două persoane, Alice și Bob, care sunt separate
de o distanță mare. Să zicem că Alice are un qubit. Îl vom numi qubit Q doar pentru comoditate. Și acesta este într-o
stare cuantică necunoscută sq, unde alpha 0 și alpha 1 sunt numere
complexe. Alice vrea să îi trimită starea ei lui Bob, dar nu are nicio modalitate de a trimite efectiv qubit-ul. S-ar putea ca
el să fie prea departe, sau poate ea nici nu știe exact unde se află Bob, deci nu știe unde să îl trimită. Din fericire,
prietenii împart deja o pereche de qubit-uri entanglate A și B, unde Alice are qubit-ul A și Bob are qubit-ul B. Și
aceste qubit-uri sunt entanglate. Prin entanglat, mă refer la faptul că, deși cele două qubit-uri sunt separate de o distanță mare,
stările lor sunt corelate într-un mod pe care fizica clasică nu îl poate explica. Această pereche entanglată este
numită Ebit, pe care o putem folosi ca resursă în calculul și comunicarea cuantică.
În acest caz, Alice poate folosi EBIT-ul ca resursă pentru a transmite informațiile sale cuantice lui Bob. Pentru a vedea cum, să
începem prin a scrie starea comună a tuturor celor trei qubit-uri, unde am ordonat qubit-urile într-un mod oarecum arbitrar
în acest moment, dar această ordine va fi convenabilă când rulăm experimentul nostru în Qiskit. În Qiskit, modul standard de
ordonare a qubit-urilor este de la dreapta la stânga. Deci, starea qubit-ului zero va apărea în dreapta.
Să extindem puțin starea și să o rescriem astfel. Apoi primul pas în protocolul nostru de teleportare este
ca Alice să entangleze qubit-ul său de date cu jumătatea sa din qubit-ul EBIT folosind un gate C-not. Un gate C-not sau controlled-NOT
va schimba starea unui qubit, qubit-ul țintă, în funcție de starea altui qubit, qubit-ul de control.
Dacă qubit-ul de control este în starea zero, atunci nu se întâmplă nimic cu ținta. Și dacă qubit-ul de control este în
starea unu, atunci qubit-ul țintă este inversat. Deci în acest caz, qubit-ul de date Q al lui Alice va fi qubit-ul de control și
qubit-ul Ebit A al ei va fi qubit-ul țintă. Deci primii doi termeni nu s-au schimbat deloc prin C-not, dar
ultimii doi termeni da, deoarece qubit-ul de control Q era în starea unu. Apoi Alice
ar aplica un gate Hadamard pe qubit-ul său de date Q, care duce starea 0 în starea 1/√2 (|0⟩ + |1⟩) și starea 1 în
1/√2 (|0⟩ - |1⟩). Voi sări peste niște algebră simplă aici pe care poți încerca să o completezi singur dacă vrei.
Dar după rearanjarea unor termeni vei obține o stare care arată astfel. Deci acum starea entanglată cu trei qubit-uri a lui Alice și Bob
arată ca un dezastru total. Dar uită-te ce se întâmplă dacă Alice măsoară ambele qubit-uri ale ei. Starea cu trei
qubit-uri se va prăbuși parțial la unul din acești patru
termeni. Și în fiecare caz, Bob va rămâne cu o stare de superpoziție cu amplitudini care sunt legate de starea inițială necunoscută a lui Alice.
Ține minte că amplitudinile sunt alpha 0 și alpha 1. Deci
de exemplu, dacă Alice măsoară ambele qubit-uri ca zero, atunci starea lui Bob se va prăbuși la acest termen, starea inițială
necunoscută pe care Alice a vrut să o teleporteze. Dar dacă Alice măsoară zero pe qubit-ul A și unu pe qubit-ul Q, atunci starea lui Bob
va fi aceasta. Această stare poate fi transformată în starea inițială a qubit-ului Q dacă Bob
aplică un gate Z, care va inversa semnul acesta. Dar Bob nu va ști să facă asta
până nu află ce a măsurat Alice. Deci următorul pas în protocol este ca Alice să îl sune pe Bob și să îi spună care
au fost cele două măsurători ale ei. După ce știe asta, va știi ce operații să efectueze asupra qubit-ului său pentru a-l face să corespundă
stării inițiale a lui Alice. Iată un tabel cu cele patru măsurători posibile și cele patru operații posibile pe care Bob
va trebui să le efectueze asupra qubit-ului său pe baza acelor măsurători. Bob ar putea trebui să aplice un gate Z, un gate X, sau ambele pentru a
transforma qubit-ul său pentru a corespunde qubit-ului inițial al lui Alice. Acest ultim pas, în care Alice îl sună pe Bob, de altfel, este motivul pentru care
teleportarea cuantică nu violează cauzalitatea. Chiar dacă starea lui Bob s-a prăbușit instantaneu când Alice și-a măsurat
qubit-urile, Bob nu putea obține nicio informație din acea stare până când Alice i-a spus lui Bob ce a măsurat. Și
acel apel era limitat de viteza luminii. Tocmai am trecut printr-o mulțime de matematică detaliată, deci faptul incredibil
că tocmai am teleportat informație cuantică poate fi trecut cu vederea. Dar este cu adevărat uimitor. Folosind
entanglement-ul ca resursă, Alice a putut face o măsurătoare pentru a distruge informația cuantică stocată la ea și a o face să apară
într-o altă locație îndepărtată la Bob. Această distanță ar putea fi de sute, chiar mii de kilometri. Și mai
uimitor, acest protocol nu necesită nici măcar ca Alice să știe exact unde se află Bob. Atâta timp cât împart un Ebit
și pot comunica clasic unul cu celălalt, teleportarea cuantică va funcționa. Acum, să vedem cum funcționează asta
WEBVTT
cu Qiskit și să teleportăm efectiv o stare cuantică pe un calculator cuantic.
Vom începe cu trei qubit-uri, câte unul pentru qubit-ul de date Q și qubit-urile A și B care vor forma E-bit-ul. Vom
începe prin crearea E-bit-ului. Aplicăm un gate Hadamard pe qubit-ul A urmat de un gate C-not
între A și B pentru a crea starea entanglată pe care o urmărim.
Apoi pregătim qubit-ul Q al lui Alice într-o stare cuantică aleatoare aplicând o unitar aleatoare reprezentată de această casetă etichetată
U. Urmează teleportarea. Mai întâi gate-ul C-not între qubit-urile Q și A. Apoi gate-ul Hadamard pe
qubit-ul Q. Apoi măsurătorile prăbușesc parțial starea astfel încât doar qubit-ul B al lui Bob se află în superpoziție.
Acesta este momentul în care Alice l-ar suna pe Bob și i-ar spune ce a măsurat. Apoi Bob ar aplica niște
gate-uri în funcție de acele măsurători. Aceste casete conturate cu roșu semnifică gate-uri condiționale. Primul înseamnă
că Bob aplică un gate X pe qubit-ul său dacă qubit-ul A este măsurat ca unu. Și
al doilea înseamnă că va aplica un gate Z, de asemenea dacă qubit-ul Q este măsurat ca unu.
Deci acum Bob ar trebui să aibă un qubit în aceeași stare în care se afla qubit-ul lui Alice în acest punct, după gate-ul unitar.
Dacă totul a mers conform planului, atunci am teleportat starea cuantică. Dar cum verificăm asta? Putem rula
același circuit, dar cu o mică modificare.
Aici am adăugat un alt unitar la sfârșitul circuit-ului aplicat qubit-ului lui Bob. Acest unitar este inversul
celui pe care l-am aplicat la început qubit-ului lui Alice. Raționamentul este că dacă acest prim gate a creat
starea cuantică care este acum teleportată la qubit-ul lui Bob, atunci acesta ar trebui să o anuleze, aducând qubit-ul lui Bob înapoi la starea zero.
Dar bineînțeles, asta anulează toată munca noastră de teleportare a stării în primul rând. Deci nu am vrea
să facem asta dacă am vrea cu adevărat să facem ceva cu starea teleportată și dacă ar fi cu adevărat într-o stare cuantică necunoscută,
nu am putea aplica un unitar pentru a o anula. Oricum, acesta este pur în scopuri de diagnosticare pentru a
ne asigura că teleportarea a avut succes. Dacă măsurăm qubit-ul lui Bob ca fiind în starea zero, atunci putem fi destul de siguri
că teleportarea a funcționat. Odată ce suntem siguri că protocolul nostru funcționează conform așteptărilor, am putea elimina acest
unitar final și să facem ceva cu adevărat cu starea teleportată. Dar deocamdată, hai să ne asigurăm că funcționează. Să
executăm circuit-ul pe un calculator cuantic. Putem folosi primitiva sampler din Qiskit pentru a rula acest circuit
de multe ori și a aduna statistici despre rezultatele măsurătorilor. Dacă am teleportat perfect starea lui Alice la Bob de fiecare
dată, atunci Bob ar măsura qubit-ul său ca zero de fiecare dată, dar cu zgomotul ambiental și imperfecțiunile din
gate-uri, ne putem aștepta să vedem unele rulări în care qubit-ul lui Bob ajunge să fie unu. Dar atâta timp cât în majoritatea
timpului qubit-ul lui Bob este măsurat ca zero, îl putem numi un succes. Iată o histogramă a rezultatelor măsurătorilor
tuturor celor trei qubit-uri. Măsurătoarea lui Bob este prezentată ca primul slot al fiecărui șir de trei biți. Conform așteptărilor, cele patru
rezultate care corespund bitului său de zero sunt mult mai probabile decât celelalte patru. Deci, am teleportat cu succes
o stare cuantică. Dar uită-te cât de departe am teleportat. Aceasta este o hartă a tuturor
qubit-urilor de pe procesorul cuantic pe care l-am folosit. Și în experiment, am folosit doar aceste trei qubit-uri.
Qubit-ul lui Alice era aici și qubit-ul lui Bob era aici. Deci, erau aproape unul lângă altul. Am fi putut
obține același lucru aplicând câteva gate-uri swap, care, după cum sugerează numele, pur și simplu schimbă stările cuantice
a două qubit-uri vecine. Teleportarea cuantică este utilă pentru transportul informațiilor cuantice pe distanțe lungi, și
stările cuantice au fost teleportate sute de kilometri înainte. Pentru experimentele noastre de aici, suntem limitați de
dimensiunea chip-ului, dar am putea face teleportarea un pic mai impresionantă teleportând o stare între două
qubit-uri îndepărtate de pe calculatorul nostru cuantic. Deci, hai să încercăm asta. Iată noul nostru circuit diagram. Arată un pic mai
complicat, dar nimic nu s-a schimbat fundamental, cu excepția faptului că acum Alice și Bob creează EBIT-ul lor comun,
apoi se separă. Această serie de linii și X-uri reprezintă gate-uri swap care mută
stările lui Alice și Bob de pe un qubit pe altul. Alice se mută în sus la qubit-ul 1 și
Bob se mută în jos la qubit-ul 12. Apoi Alice creează starea sa aleatoare pe qubit-ul 0 cu
acest unitar. Ține minte că ea creează starea după ce ea și Bob s-au
separat deja. Deci Bob este deja departe de ea.
Apoi protocolul de teleportare continuă ca înainte și Bob ajunge cu starea inițială a lui Alice după
operațiile sale condiționale. Aplicăm gate-ul unitar invers și verificăm că qubit-ul lui Bob este
în starea zero. Și din nou vedem că în majoritatea timpului qubit-ul lui Bob a fost găsit în starea zero.
Deci teleportarea a avut succes.
Rata de succes nu este chiar la fel de mare ca atunci când Alice și Bob erau unul lângă altul. Toate acele gate-uri swap
pot fi costisitoare și pot cauza degradarea EBIT-ului un pic. Teleportarea cuantică poate părea magie, dar după cum am
văzut, tot ce este nevoie este entanglement, un canal de comunicare clasic și puțină ingeniozitate. Propunerea originală din 1993
pe care am acoperit-o în acest videoclip a pus bazele pentru alte protocoale, cum ar fi teleportarea gate-ului cuantic,
și este un ingredient esențial pentru calculul și comunicațiile cuantice.
Pe frontul experimental, oamenii de știință au continuat să împingă limitele teleportării cuantice, reușind chiar să teleporteze
starea cuantică a unui foton între un laborator de pe Pământ și un satelit la 1.400 km
deasupra lui. Și să teleporteze stări cuantice printr-un cablu clasic de internet cu zgomot. Dacă vrei să teleportezi propria ta
stare cuantică, accesează modulul de teleportare cuantică legat în descrierea de mai jos. Mulțumesc că ai urmărit
și ne vedem data viitoare.